diese ausbildung ist sehr vielfältig
geht natürlich auch in verschiedene
abteilungen richtungen wir haben kunden
umgehen umgehen soll
zu gehen hat was man bestellen soll also
wien bestellt wird jede menge sachen
über die wahre allgemeinen laden aufbau
bisher ablaufen sollen er muss sich mit
lebensmitteln auseinandersetzen er muss
spaß an den lebensmittel haben
man muss eigentlich sehr offen sein muss
blitzschnell umschalten können also von
der einen situation in die andere bei
uns ist das so dass letztendlich nicht
nur gelernte mitarbeiter bei uns
anfangen können sondern wir können auch
mit einem aushilfstätigkeit hier
anfangen und schon mal reinschnuppern
oder ein praktikum machen und sich dann
langsam an den beruf gewöhnen und wenn
die sagen mensch das ist was für mich
das passt da habe ich lust daran dann
ist da auf jeden fall einem gespräch
bereit wo wir dann über eine einstellung
sprechen können bzw
einstellungen als auszubildender für
verkäufer verkäuferinnen oder auch
kauffrau oder kaufmann im 1 unsere
azubis die können
wirklich sehr weit kommen also da gehen
wir nun wirklich viele möglichkeiten sie
können hier in erster linie den
ausbildungsberuf als verkäufer
durchlaufen
das wäre eine zweijährige ausbildung und
die zum einzelhandelskaufmann wählen
dreijährige und danach kann man noch so
ein landes bach wird machen bei uns ist
es so dass wir auch denjenigen die
chance geben hier eine abteilung alleine
zu führen wo er selbst wo er
möglichkeiten hat selbstständig zu
bestellen oder auch die aufbauten und
alles selber machen oder wo auch nachher
mehr sachen sind das ja auch in die
marktleitung mit reinkommen kann ein
markt mit führen kann erst mal als
substitut später eventuell sogar als
marktleiter also da sind letztendlich
chancen ohne ende gewesen gegeben ja
einfach der umgang mit menschen noch
machen wenn sie besonders viel spaß und
das war sehr viel über die wahren lehrt
dass man also meinen weiß nicht viel
über die ware allgemeinen weil wir auch
selber die verzehren vielleicht aber so
hätten auch wenn man damit arbeitet wo
die ware herkommt wie hergestellt wird
oder wo zumal ja auch überhaupt braucht
ich finde das tolle an dem beruf das
waren unheimlich viele möglichkeiten hat
weiterzukommen
eine selbstständige arbeit verrichten
kann und jemand der gerne ist und dazu
wirklich jetzt macht gutes glas wein
trinken möchte der ist einfach in so
einem supermarkt richtig aufgehoben